like all of you I'm proud to call Las
Vegas home I met my wife here my kids
were born here and I know how special
this city is to all the brave first
responders that have worked tirelessly
and courageously throw this whole
tragedy we thank you to the families and
friends of the victims know that we'll
do everything we can to help you in our
city heal we are Vegas strong how is
Derek England of the Las Vegas Golden
Knights on October 10th the night that
Las Vegas hockey came into being in the
NHL their home schedule opening up nine
days after the massacre in Las Vegas
cost more than 50 lives and injured more
than 500 people and after that speech
the Golden Knights took the ice England
scored one of the five goals on the
night and now here they are
months later getting set to board a
flight to Winnipeg for the Western
Conference Finals and Derek England
joining us here on the roadshow how are
you Derek I'm fine well how did how does
your hearing your words back all these
months later now knowing that your your
step away from playing for the Stanley
Cup potentially how do those words hit
you now Derek
[Music]
oh it just brings back something for
myself get up and be able to speak speak
those words to all the people that were
there and the people that were listening
and you know it's just an honor to be
able to do that and again you you you go
back you're originally from Canada but
you go back to Vegas for your with your
Las Vegas Wranglers days in the ECHL
well over ten years ago correct yeah
yeah I've been basically living in Vegas
since those days since oh three so about
15 years just going back to the
at night in October when you took the
microphone how long did you think about
what you were gonna say to the crowd
that night I was trying to memorize it
for probably four or five days when I
found out I was gonna do that it's
probably both the only thing that was
going through my head for four or five
days there's just any moment just say it
over and over until I you know knew I
knew it too off by heart and you know
I'm not a big public speaker or anything
so it's pretty nervous doing that yeah
well you you you nailed it to say the
least and I'm wondering how how that has
fueled this run that we have seen I
definitely think the beginning of season
a hundred percent you know it brought us
together
you know quicker I think and brought us
together with the community a lot
quicker than you know if that didn't
happen which which is horrible to say
but you know God our team out the
community trying to help in any way they
could and you know I think guys as soon
as that happened we're wanting to do as
much they could and you know from the
start
starting Dallas to the first home game
it wasn't we weren't we weren't playing
for points we're playing for the city
and and the people that were affected by
it you know just hearing after games how
much three hours of the hockey was
helping people forget for a few hours
what happened and thought it was try to
get past it you know guys were really
excited that they're doing that much
just just by playing a hockey game so it
became you know we wanted to win for for
the city the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience